one of the best known tools for batch
processing raster and vector images is
image magic
image magic is a free and open source
tool that enables you to automate just
about anything you might normally do
with a gui based image editor such as
converting formats
or cropping or applying filters
now for responsive images this means you
can automate the process of creating
multiple versions of the same image with
different sizes or formats
in this example i'm using the image
magic convert command to create a webp
goanna
let's open those in chrome
identical cool thing is the webp goanna
is about 10 smaller than the jpeg
that can make quite a difference on a
flaky connection
in this example i've written a shell
script that uses image magic to create
small and large versions of my original
photographic images saving in webp and
jpeg formats
note the massive reduction in file sizes
there's my original goanna and these are
the versions that i created
you can incorporate image magic in your
build process via a grunt task
in this example i'm using grunt
responsive images to automate production
of images
just like i did with the shell script
and then you can see the output
got a bunch of images saved at fifty
percent width and thirty percent width
in jpeg format at uh
different quality sizes
there are a couple of really useful apps
that combine other tools for image
optimization for example imageoptim
enables lossless image optimization
using a number of open source tools png
out png crush jpeg optim
gifsicle and so on now look at the file
sizes of our images before and after
image alpha uses png quant and other
tools for compression image alpha can
reduce 24 bit png files by applying
lossy compression and converting to png8
plus alpha format
look at our png sizes before and after
looking at that it went down from about
330 kilobytes to around about 118 that's
like around half the size
as well as the gui versions you've just
seen tools like image optim and image
alpha can also be run from the command
line and incorporated with your build
process
in this example i'm running image optim
as a grunt task
that means you can incorporate automated
image optimization in your workflow
to learn more about grunt along with
image optim and other command line tools
follow the links below the video